drunk
welcome to a super cult production of
congratulations
[Music]
just touch down just touch down
we touch down dude we're back
we were back um
from the road you know and it's great if
you like this podcast which you do
because you're listening you know
um and you're in our cult this is how it
is um and if you're if you like the
podcast subscribe to super cold studios
subscribe to the page we put out this we
put out lifeline i'm sporting a lifeline
merch here you can go to crystalia.com
to get all the merch you need
lifeline and uh the and the crystalia
merch and uh well the [ __ ] uh the the
congratulations podcast merch and all
that [ __ ] man we had tour exclusive
merch that's going selling like hotcakes
we were in atlanta and dc but it's all
good we'll get to that um i appreciate
you listening but like and subscribe to
the channel man i can't break [ __ ]
596
000 i don't understand what it is
and uh and i don't understand what it is
all i know is that there's that i can't
break that and i can't get the money out
of my [ __ ] tick tock account because
i don't know the god damn
what do you call it uh
what do they call it the [ __ ] i don't
know the code or whatever that get the
[ __ ] thing in the token that the
extra app that they have to use i don't
want to do it the authenticator app
figured it out dude need ginkgo biloba
all good dude but you can go to uh
chrisley.com get your [ __ ] wrinkle
life rip shits
puffy as [ __ ] dude or the new brown
choco shits life rips hell yeah those
are nice and dusty because they've been
over there near my floor whatever though
dude we got hoodies on the floor
um
that sounds like it would be a rap song
and uh and that's what's up dude uh like
and subscribe
just popped in one of my pure spectrum
gummies
right there
let me tell you something to keep me
happy
i swear to god there's no thc involved
and they keep me happy as [ __ ] they keep
me at a level dude i barely get [ __ ]
frustrated i do the meet and greets and
my [ __ ] and i meet a hundred people and
i'm just asking them questions like i'm
interested dude
and i'm not even i don't feel high but
i'm just like wait a minute am i happy
is this a cbd i don't know but we've got
the
link in the show notes down below and
you can get 10 off if you click that and
use the promo code congrats for all your
cb cbd stuff um there's actually can you
hear me there's actually so many cbd
shits there's face cream and everything
there's bath salts i don't know what the
[ __ ] man
um
but yeah dude
so that's what's up we're here living
the sober lifestyle
we're living a sober lifestyle
i love when i go to the um
cities and i do the meet and greets
because you know i sell like 100 tickets
for a meet and greet after the shows
and uh sometimes i see people that are
in the meet and greets that are actually
in the um
on the discord in my patreon if you want
to get the patreon patreon.com
but um
and uh
and i i met someone that said
um
that uh
she was like you shouted me out on your
i remembered i was like i know you
um i just remember her from the discord
because i see everyone chat and all that
[ __ ] and i i chime in but she was like i
know i was like i know you and she's
like yeah you shouted me out on your
podcast once i was eight months sober
and i was like oh yeah and she was like
i'm proud to announce now that i'm 25
months sober dude
and um
good on her man congrats to her
fighting the good fight but uh i love
hearing that and uh i met i met some
other people on the discord and [ __ ]
it's just cool it's just cool why does
my [ __ ] thing keep going out yes dude
it keeps going out
that's annoying but it's all good my
babies
um
so i went to let's see i went to
atlanta and washington dc look you never
know what you're going to get on the
road you never know what you're going to
get i touched down atlanta brought the
[ __ ] family
it was beautiful
brought the family long flight calvin
[ __ ] killed it
uh on the flight was great
playing his pad he wants to play his pad
he's getting hooked on screens maybe
is the boy getting hooked on screens
maybe did i always want to be this the
father that
had pride in the sun when he was at a
restaurant not using an ipad
yeah i did dude is he using an ipad no
is he using a different kind of pad that
has games on it yes do we [ __ ] say
that that's not the same thing to make
us feel better yes we do dude
but we're good parents
because we limit the pad use but he
always wants to use the pad i'll tell
you man
he always wants to use the pad he wants
to play he wants to play games on the
pad so what the [ __ ] dude
um
so we use that you know he has
he gets to eat what the [ __ ] he wants on
flight days and he also gets to play
what the [ __ ] he wants on flight days
but the problem is we have so many
[ __ ] flight days so
it's like he gets to eat whatever you
want do whatever we want pretty much
every [ __ ] three days out of the week
which is way too many days dude there's
only two days on a week on a weekend
that's when everyone does whatever the
[ __ ] they want my son has three so it's
like
i don't know i'm flying around you know
i'm not using masks and [ __ ] it's like
oh i'm gonna be in oakland coming up and
they they uh you don't have to be
vaccinated to get in i thought the city
of oakland was gonna make you vaccinate
yourself
uh to get to my show and i double
checked on that thank god dude i'm not
gonna do anything where you have unless
they pay me like a bajillion dollars i
don't want to do anything where like
they're making you do [ __ ] i i don't
like that and um i think i got one show
coming up where they're like the city is
mandating masks because the show's too
big whatever he fills [ __ ] seats up
but um
i'm not gonna do it moving forward i'm
not doing that it's so uncomfortable to
be sitting with a [ __ ] mask on and
i've been flying everywhere and i'm not
getting [ __ ] covered so it's like
whatever dude maybe i'm irresponsible if
he's irresponsible
i don't know dude maybe i'm living maybe
the wrong guy maybe i'm the wronger side
of history maybe i am but who knows
until history happens
um
and i'm not even you know i'm not
republican or democrat dude i'm me and
don't push me i say but dude
you know
um
so yeah and you can go get other tickets
at chrisley.com i'll be in savannah
georgia and raleigh north carolina um
and denver and just all sorts of [ __ ]
crazy stockton
i'm gonna hopefully get a bulletproof
vest um
[Music]
yeah i went to atlanta and atlanta's
great atlanta has some weird [ __ ]
people in it you know
like atlanta has weird
shaped people
like i don't understand what's going on
with atlanta's people
white black doesn't matter that's pretty
much all that's in atlanta but it
doesn't matter what race you are you're
weirdly shaped dude
they've got regular people that are good
looking but you'll have like someone in
atlanta that has like an ass on their
shoulders
and you're just like
how do you [ __ ]
laying down
i don't understand that people in
atlanta their jaw will just like come
the [ __ ] out further than their nose and
they'll have an ass on their shoulders
and they'll just be like
someone that works at a bank
not at a carnival you know
anyone with an ass on their shoulders
anywhere else in the country works
in a tent
they work around many collars and flags
and [ __ ]
and things that twist and turn too much
but in atlanta that guy
that guy works as a barista and he's
just like can i take your order
what the [ __ ] up with the
shapes of atlanta's people
people be walking around there like six
hexagons and a hat
i don't understand
it's so crazy dude it's insane
um
and we were in atlanta and i'm walking
around atlanta like dude in atlanta you
[ __ ] like b.o.b came out to my show
that's a good-looking [ __ ] i
can't lie that's a good-looking
[ __ ] you know and if i were
black right now i'd be like pause but
i'm white and i don't say pause i stand
by it and i know i'm hetero
but he's a good looking [ __ ] he
came out to my show he brought some
merch i meant to wear it for the podcast
[ __ ] i'll have to wear it next time
brought me some strange clouds hats
or something and a [ __ ] shirt
with when i wear it looks like i [ __ ]
smoke weed dude and i'm a hip dude i'm
i'm hip i'm cool i want to [ __ ]
support the homies but b.o.b came out
had some cool pants on and we [ __ ]
love b.o.b in this family dude
strange clouds
um
you know
uh so yeah he came out
and um
we did the show in atlanta it was great
2700 people came out who up stood
twenty twenty seven thousand people came
out ups and we had a good time and lulu
gonzalez went up and [ __ ] killed it
it was really cool man because she's
like i don't know if you've been doing
stand-up i thought she had been doing
stuff for longer because she's very
funny about i think you've been doing it
for like eight years
and uh i saw at the laugh factor i was
like this [ __ ] she's very funny and i
wanted her to come on tour with me and i
brought her on tour and i think that she
was like i mean i think what she said
she was like this is the biggest crowd
she's ever played and i felt it felt
really cool because she was so excited
and we did the atlanta show and the
atlanta show was great
um
and then we did and then i brought and
then mike linoche went on and then i
went on right
and then we packed up and we [ __ ]
went to dc and i'll get into dc but when
we went to dc let me tell you like what
i say is on the road you never know what
you're gonna get and the atlanta crowd
was hot as [ __ ] dude the atlanta crowd
was great thank you atlanta and i love
atlanta i bleed atlanta do you know what
i mean my soul is in atlanta in a way
and uh i have an atlanta soul so sue me
right so and then when i went to
washington dc i'm always like i never
know like what side
washington dc is going to be a when it
comes to the humor [ __ ] like when you go
to san francisco you can't do certain
jokes i still do them baby what's it
matter now i still do them
right what are you gonna take from me at
this point and uh but dc
you know i go on stage and i talk about
the [ __ ] i make jokes about you know
different sides of the spectrum and i
never know how it's gonna land and let
me tell you something dude i thought dc
was gonna be more liberal than it was
and holy [ __ ] dude that crowd
was so happy that i was pushing dude
that crowd was so happy i was pushing
man
that crowd was loving it
3 000 people were [ __ ]
just and and lulu went up and
holy [ __ ] dude lulu went up and just
from jump boom dude
and then mike went up and
ba boom
and then what and then i went up and you
know you know how the story goes right i
don't like to be [ __ ] egotistical but
boom right of course
i mean they came for me
and um
man dude that dc [ __ ] i did a little bit
of roast to the [ __ ] dc i'll put it
on my second channel the crystallia
channel on youtube
put a little stand up on there and maybe
some for my tic tocs because you know i
put it up there [ __ ] because now i
[ __ ] shoot everything because you got
to shoot everything no matter what
you're doing if you're a [ __ ]
celebrity you have to shoot everything
unless you're leonardo dicaprio or
[ __ ]
um
will smith oh smith [ __ ] shoots
everything unless you're ryan gosling or
leonardo dicaprio you got to shoot
everything you got to be like
i had a doctor's appointment the other
day and i literally was like where's my
camera guy and i was like wait this is
doctor's appointment
mr delia you're dying
like those [ __ ] tick tocks
or no [ __ ]
some other guys there and tick-tock
doing a [ __ ] sick a bull dunk dung
some girl showing her ass
just farting on my coffin saga ball
i thought it was saying soccer ball but
whatever you guys don't even know that
that song's from the beat nuts i do dude
because i'm an og
i could see him right there by the
window that's in one of those [ __ ]
songs beatnut song
um
so yeah so [ __ ] i got a guy following
me everywhere it's all good i got my own
version of tmz
um and it's all good dude
tmz came up to me the other day talking
about david arnold the rest in peace
david arnold i can't believe we [ __ ]
lost him he's like 54 he had two
daughters and a wife man that guy was a
funny [ __ ] and he was just about
to hit dude
uh he had a second netflix special come
out he's just starting to do some
theaters
[ __ ] sharp dress man always looking
real good being funny just charismatic
as [ __ ] and he just had a heart attack
and felon hit his [ __ ] head dude and
we love david arnold man and uh
you know we've been losing a lot of
comedians lately him teddy ray and jack
knight and uh it's just rough man it's
rough
it's rough when anyone loses anyone um
but rest in peace to those three and
then most recently david arnold um
yeah he was a good one man i was just
[ __ ] talking to him
um i just did a show with him at the
laugh factory it's [ __ ] it's brutal
uh
yeah
but uh so um
what was i going to say i was going to
talk about dc i was going to get i went
to dc
and um did i put it in my notes i barely
[ __ ] wrote any notes i'm good at this
dude
i go to dc and
like dc is a very interesting city
washington dc because washington dc is a
very very interesting city um
but the thing about washington dc that
always blows my mind first of all the
white house looks like it's every other
building looks like the white house
which is [ __ ] crazy like
[ __ ]
so many columns
like there's so many columns everywhere
like it's just some [ __ ] grand like
where are we rome you know it's [ __ ]
and we went to visit
the uh capitol building and we saw
you know everything up there with the
capitol building um and they were all
like scaffolding and [ __ ] and you go up
to them and you're like hey is uh
what are you redoing the place and
they're like well just making sure that
this the structure the integrity of the
structure is uh sound after the and
you're like dude this is just so people
[ __ ] can't get in right
because we're supposed to be able to
[ __ ] walk right up to it hey just
walk right up
and um
and yeah it's crazy
you look at the [ __ ] walls on the
capitol building
they have like steps on them like
like grooves in them like it may it's
it's like they're inviting you to just
like climb up
those [ __ ] uh what do you call it
the policemen were just standing there
and when the [ __ ] january six
insurgents were crawling up they would
just be like
and whoa
they're just like got it and the police
would just be like
with their [ __ ] hands oh and then
but what's crazy about [ __ ]
washington dc is here's the thing you
need an update washington dc okay
you need an update all right do you know
why
because
in like the year
1850 there weren't that many people
when was the car made
like 19 something or before that
19 000
1900s and like eight you know i know i
read a book about henry ford when i was
in [ __ ] school dude
and um
there's a picture book and so and he
like
in in 1850
it was fine to have i like everything so
close each other like the washington
monument like the [ __ ] uh the lincoln
memorial
man i always think when i see that when
i think of the washington monument i
always think of uh what's his name talib
kweli saying
and my cash looked more like dixon
washington monument so bad um
and our cash look more like dixon and
washington monuments so bad and so um
and real hip hop heads would be like but
that's real hip hop you know i mean
that's real hip hop
akash look like dicks more than the
washington one if you want to know if
hip-hop lyrics are actually really good
say them in a radio announcer voice
you know what i mean
like when you hear yoshore it's your
birthday oh shorty and you know we don't
give a [ __ ] it's your birthday like
you're like [ __ ] yeah dude in vegas
that's nice
but when you're when you say it like go
shorty it's your birthday and you know
we don't give a [ __ ] because it's not
your birthday then you realize okay it's
actually bad
our cash stack more like dicks
than the washington monument
um tonight at 11 and so
anyway
um it was fine in 1850 okay
but hey it's 2022.
not only are there [ __ ] bicycles not
only are there cars but there's ubers
someone will just drive you
four blocks away
to wear
the president
lives
should be illegal
dude
you can just
walk up
to where the leader of the free world
resides
hey that's gotta change because of
dirty bombs and crazy people
i want my president living way out there
just like in a side of a [ __ ]
mount i want him safe i don't give a
[ __ ] who it is trump
the lizard biden it doesn't matter
i don't care who it is
you know whether it's trump or [ __ ]
joe biden and if he's just fresh from
the ocean and he [ __ ] shed his scales
and he came back into this white house i
want the white house in the side of a
[ __ ] mountain in the middle of some
place where there's other mountains that
look just like it and we can't tell
which mountain it's in dude it's so
insane that in this day and age
that you can just hey just walk right up
you could be staying at a w hotel and
just
walk three blocks
and yell for the president through his
wind
i'm in room 315 at the
at the w hotel if you want to come in
i'm getting [ __ ] sliders
biden trying to sleep god damn it
this is a lizard
um
but yeah dude that's got to change this
is why i say tradition ruins everything
because the president lives there still
because he lived there for since 17 or
whatever the [ __ ] it was you know i'm
bad with dates
but
you
need to update that [ __ ] with the time
tradition ruins everything wars and
every but even more than religion
tradition
religion is tradition any tradition is
[ __ ] up right my dad used to want to
read the [ __ ] what was the
train christmas book what's that called
polar express every christmas day he
wanted to read it and that was cool when
i was six and 11.
but dude he we had to stop him like five
years i'm 42.
five years ago i'm like dad i just you
know it's like
i don't i it's fine i get it he's just
like but the magic of christmas and i'm
like
i'm 37.
that's fine can you can we just not read
it he's like but it's tradition then you
get me all pent up and then before you
know it i don't want to come over for
christmas that's a very micro to the
world's macro but i'm saying that kind
of [ __ ] is the micro and the macro is
walking up to the [ __ ] white house
and rocket launcher in the new [ __ ]
device the vp
um
yeah i mean it's crazy to just pop in an
uber and be like the white house
like i get it america but also
chill right
[Music]
and now a word from our sponsor better
help listen okay just listen
i struggle with a lot mentally i
struggle with
uh my mental health i struggle with
solving problems and
therapy is very important it can be
tough to train your brain to stay in
problem-solving mode when faced with a
challenge in life that's natural but
when you learn how to find your own
solutions
the feeling is unbelievable it's
beautiful
uh you start feeling like you're in a
movie and you can walk on water and it
feels great it feels like you are taking
control of your own life a therapist can
help you become a better problem solver
making it easier to accomplish this and
easier to accomplish your goals no
matter how big or small take it from me
i use therapy i use it all the time i do
it i i don't just do it once a week i'm
in constant contact with my therapist
and it has quite honestly been a reason
that uh has saved my life and uh if if
you struggle with anything like that
problem solving mental health depression
whatever it is i have ocd
um
if you're thinking of giving therapy a
try better help is a great option it's
convenient it's accessible affordable
and entirely online
you know in that way it's a lot easier
than getting in your car and driving to
a therapist it's hard to find a
therapist
uh in real in actual person um and this
is online and it's a lot cheaper um you
can get matched with a therapist after
filling out a brief survey and switch
therapists at any time um
so listen when you want to be a better
problem solver therapy can get you there
visit betterhelp.com
congratulations today to get 10 off your
first month that's betterh-e-l-p-com
congratulations thanks
[Music]
i don't know it's all [ __ ] the
world's gone to [ __ ] dude it's fine the
queen died and that's another thing dude
there you go tradition
so [ __ ] annoying oh there's still
queens and kings
dude
huh
hey
that's that first of all that's insane
you know what they're gonna be queens
and kings until you build cars
if you have cars which pretty much we
all do no kings and queens anymore like
if you're [ __ ] working
you know
in south africa trying to mine blood
diamonds
and you got to get everywhere with like
one jeep and a few [ __ ] lions or
whatever
or you know what like what you've got
like two jeeps and then other men carry
everyone else then there can be a king
right because you need to [ __ ] make
people want to carry you
but if you've got like multiple cars and
[ __ ] and trains and airplanes dude
no queens no kings
it's insane
it's so weird and she died and now the
[ __ ] guy with the [ __ ]
sausage fingers got to be the king
you see his hands
he looks like uh what's that [ __ ]
scene from big
little big
china whatever [ __ ] big trouble in
little china when the guy blows up
he looks like he's [ __ ] five percent
into that scene
what's his name charles
prince now he's king charles and he's
like 70 what you know
god that guy
i'm just hoping he should [ __ ] die
soon you know with his little sausage
[ __ ] with his with his farmer john
fingers i know it's just you know of
course oh
all glory to the queen but it's just
like you know you know what happens when
she dies right
my sausage fingers get more rings on it
you know what happens right
i got to be the king night's fine like
it's all good and i want her to be the
queen but it's like you know happens
when she dies all right i'll become the
most important man
and then she died and just goes like
this all right and we [ __ ] go she
died and he was just like
his [ __ ] sausage fingers putting on
the ray-bans
[Laughter]
putting on the aviators what happened
what happened she died
what happened the queen thought
[Music]
hit the wrong button [ __ ] yeah dude
um
so now he's the [ __ ] king and he's
the king and he's gonna die in like five
years dude
the lengthy he was the queen for like
900 years and he's gonna be the king for
six months
talk about the [ __ ] raw end dude he
could have just been s scooping that
[ __ ] up and now he's just like you know
it doesn't work right
he just now he's just gotta [ __ ] be
like ruling
y'all so you're not doing [ __ ] at that
point when you're ruling a country and
you're [ __ ] 75.
i feel like the president actually does
real work and the king's just like
you know bring me some more lemonade
and don't allow blacks in here
apparently like she was so racist but
she had [ __ ] 45 dogs and she treated
the dogs better than the minorities or
something the queen i don't know i don't
mean to [ __ ] i have no idea this
podcast you come here for hard-hitting
news but honestly i'm going to tell you
when i don't know and i don't know
i'm the [ __ ] king of england
how about that how about [ __ ] that
how about them apples i got a number how
about them apples i watched that movie i
walked in the other day and kristen was
like watching [ __ ] you know it's like
i love her she saved my [ __ ] life
dude she's a princess and i love her she
saved my life she's one of the reasons
i'm still here today dude and i walked
in and she was watching [ __ ] goodwill
hunting and i just go god damn it i want
to watch something bad i don't like good
movies dude and she was like i never saw
it before and she said it her voice was
all christmasy and it was beautiful
and i was just like okay well oh yeah
and she was like is it a good it's a
good movie and i was like it is a good
movie you know but those movies i only
want to watch once really fantastic deep
emotional movies i want to watch them
once and then i'm out now that's because
me for 38 years of my life i didn't want
to feel my feelings yes that's because
38 for 38 years of my life i kept my
walls up and i didn't want to experience
loneliness yes of course dude and i kept
my face in my phone because i thought
that that meant i was cool being alone
but really i was just distracting my
loneliness yes we did that dude and i've
learned that in therapy and it's all
good but
now i have to watch movies and i have to
cry and that [ __ ] is too much so i'm
watching goodwill hunting i've seen it
once and i know i cried during the movie
just like i [ __ ] cried during the
movie braveheart i've seen it once okay
and i've never seen braveheart again
because it's too emotional and there's
too much brown in it
okay
and um
to be frank there's too much brown and
good with hunting too it's just too much
it's just like
put colors in it more you know have blue
in the [ __ ] thing and um
and i'm watching goodwill and she's like
sit down watch it with me and like i
didn't really want to but then i was
like this movie's so good if i just sit
down and watch it for like five minutes
i bet i'll hook into it but i i'll then
resent
that i did that because i didn't want to
do that and now that i
and i'm basically just trick this is the
kind of mind [ __ ] and [ __ ] i go
through i don't want to watch goodwill
hunting she wants me to watch goodwill
hunting i know it's a good movie i'd
probably like it if i sat down and
started watching it but i don't want to
but i should do that for her so i'm
going to sit down and try to [ __ ]
just experience it and then maybe i'll
hook into it and want to watch the rest
of it but then i'm gonna be secretly
upset with her because she kind of
called the shots
absolutely [ __ ] insane those were all
the thoughts i went through okay no
[ __ ] i'm being honest with you guys
even though i don't want to right
i'm sitting there with a [ __ ] disney
princess she's the [ __ ] love of my
life right this is what's happening
and i'm the [ __ ] guy going through
all this [ __ ] and she's just sitting
watching [ __ ] robin williams
just like but you don't know what it
feels like to look in person at the
[ __ ] goddamn mona lisa what the [ __ ]
he says
sistine chapel
and so now i'm sitting there and then
she's like [ __ ]
[ __ ] gotta start school and i'm like
what what
20 minutes into me sitting watching
goodwill hunting gotta start [ __ ] [ __ ]
gotta start school and i'm like huh
she's like i got my zoom class
i'm a therapist and i'm like
so you can't watch the rest i'll watch
it later if you want and i'm like
the [ __ ] i hooked in
i [ __ ] hooked into the movie i didn't
want to hook in
i gotta do class if i miss one more i
fail i do
because you went to a [ __ ] because
you had to go to the bridesmaids thing
right [ __ ] [ __ ] dude so you can't
miss another class because you went to
the [ __ ]
the bachelorette party right now i got
to sit and i got [ __ ] now i gotta sit
and i don't even wanna watch a movie and
i'm in so i wanna watch a movie even
though i don't wanna watch a movie i
gotta watch this [ __ ] thing
fine she does school and then she's like
can you actually watch it upstairs and
i'm like you ch
you're ch i didn't know what now i gotta
go in another room and do some [ __ ] i
don't want to do even though i want to
do it
so i'm watching [ __ ] you know and i
realize oh you saved my life and your
[ __ ] disney princess and i love you
but now i got to sit and watch him
[ __ ] alone
like it's not your fault he's like i
know i you know
that's not your fault don't [ __ ] with me
it's not your fault dumb [ __ ] and i'm
sitting here and cows crashing a [ __ ]
dino truck into my leg
and i'm hooked in i watch all the
goodwill hunting again i watched the
[ __ ] thing again you had to go see
about a girl that's what happened at the
end
it's [ __ ] like two three callbacks in
that movie that make you cry your
[ __ ] eyes out
so i watched it dude i watched it again
i'll be damned if i watch [ __ ]
braveheart again though i'll tell you
that much
look at this [ __ ] time magazine thing
from 1973
the man who will be king and here he is
prince charles britain's prince charles
49 years ago dude
imagine making the cover of a [ __ ]
thing this guy's gonna be king look at
him so happy leaning up against a tree
49 years go by and then he's he's like
no i don't even [ __ ] want the thing
god damn it so i
don't even [ __ ] get that [ __ ]
what's important have a king being a
king and i'm going to get [ __ ] suck
jobs it's not
so anyway alright peter the queen
i got a [ __ ] cut here in my head like
you ever wake up with a cut this is the
this hurts so bad you can see it's on my
forehead if you're listening to it it
looks like a mini [ __ ] stab wound
that somebody did it with a pocket
uh swiss army knife i woke up and just
all of a sudden
how does this happen dude it's like the
same kind of mystery as like where did
my other sock go you know what i'm
talking about it's like it's got to be
somewhere in this room
i just washed it and now the washing
machine ate it
do you ever wake up with a cut or a
bruise and you're like okay well
aliens switched my body out to another
version of my body because i didn't hit
my [ __ ] head last night
and then today kristen's like you're
bruised what what happened and i was
like it happened [ __ ] i woke up in
with d in dc and she was like i i said
did you notice it and she said yeah i
was like why the [ __ ] didn't you say
anything about it she's like i don't
know i was like did you [ __ ] stat
did you just [ __ ] while i was
sleeping
with your [ __ ] finger
take a chunk out
and it's hurt so much more than it
should do it and i'm a real man
a cow fell and hit his [ __ ] eye today
but he's he's okay
god when he falls down i just
i just always tell him the worst part's
over
you already hurt you're done love you
buddy you're all good
oh dude and he was eating
at this place today he was eating more
than i have ever seen him eat like and i
know this sounds boring and [ __ ] but
just wait for it okay it gets better
but you know like that's the last thing
i want to hear is like how your son or
daughter eats you know
so his appetite actually lately it's
like [ __ ] snooze city
i don't want to hear what you ate
i don't even care what i ate honestly i
forget
try to think about what you ate for
lunch you can remember no
right i can't remember
a tuna bowl
took me a bit and so um
calvin was eating
we went to this place i got the tuna
bowl he got the [ __ ] eggs
he wanted i said what do you want calvin
he said eggs so it's like oh great he
[ __ ] he rarely says what he wants
he either wants eggs or [ __ ] you know
macaron rose that's macaroni because
what mom used to call it and that's what
called it to him and he took it and ran
with it it's all good
and uh or he wants bacon okay can't
always have bacon obviously macaroons
are very easy because we have macaroni
in the kitchen because we're italian and
eggs is very easy to make if we don't
have it even if we don't have it but we
were at the place he wanted eggs so we
got eggs i was eating my tuna bowl and
he was eating his eggs and i have never
seen him eat better than than this he
was shoveling those [ __ ] eggs in his
mouth and i was like [ __ ] yeah dude this
is the moment where he turns into a
[ __ ] boy because if you know anything
about my son which you probably know a
lot about my son if you listen to this
podcast regularly because i talk about
him quite often but he's good at
everything except doesn't want to eat
always wants to play i'm like are you
hungry and he goes i know i'm not
you know
and stomps do you want i i gotta p do
you want cheerios no i
don't okay
eggs i
don't okay i gotta guess what do you
want and then finally this time he's
like eggs so i'm like eggs and he's
shoveling the [ __ ] in his mouth like did
we get a [ __ ] did we crack the code
did we figure out a [ __ ] life hack
right
and so he's eating the [ __ ] i mean boy's
eating so fast and he's using the fork
he never used the fork he wants to use
his hand he's using a fork putting it in
his mouth dude he's doing it like me
like i always like to have a piece of
food in my mouth and when i swallow
there's another piece of food in my
mouth because i always want the flavor
explosion in my mouth when the shit's
traveling down my esophagus and there's
nothing in my mouth that's wasted time i
want it always in my mouth there's food
always in my mouth it's replacing the
food sliding down my esophagus
it's always replacing the food sliding
down so i always have a [ __ ]
explosion of flavor in my mouth that's
always how i do it dude
and i'm like calvin is doing like like
father like son and he's eating eggs and
eats the whole bowl dude and he takes a
sip of spicy water which is what we call
club sun
is on spicy water and so he eats the
[ __ ] club so he starts drinking the
club soda and we think the bubbles are
getting to him in his head because he's
going like this like this and like you
like the spicy water and she's like oh
something's going on and he just goes
dude when i tell you it was like a
sprinkler went off
it was like an egg sprinkler
went the f it was like a a geyser went
off sideways slowly
it wasn't
and it kept come all the eggs and then
eggs from a past life just shot just
spilled out
and kristen goes whoop like she was
ozzie smith just scooping a bouncer
just caught all of the eggs all of his
spit up
and then he goes
ah
because of scary [ __ ]
when you're two and a half you don't he
has never thrown up that much he
probably thought why did my insides come
out so i picked him up
and i held him and i said to him and he
was crying and he said hey buddy that's
okay you know what that happens to me
sometimes too and he stopped crying and
he said it does and i said yeah it
happens everybody and he [ __ ] took a
deep breath
and that was it dude
and it was a beautiful [ __ ] moment
because we're all human and let's not
forget that dude
and i love being a dad
and i love being a dad especially when
my son throws up with eggs
because um i want him to feel
comfortable and i want to make him feel
comfortable and i want to be a good dad
about that
and then asked the guy for some milk so
calvin have some milk and he brought
over milk and he was like
no he didn't bring it over he brought
over a cup of ice and he was like you
you want
he was like you want um
[Music]
ice with the milk
and i was like
you're not from earth
with milk
honestly
if you drink
milk with ice in it
i want you to unsubscribe from my
podcast
i want you
to shake hands with me
it's been fun thank you i enjoy if you
listen to every episode great i loved
having you listen
but it's time we part ways
and i looked at them and i was like and
i said no
no thank you just the milk is fine
and kristen laughed and i said what and
she was like just you and i was like no
[Music]
no i'm not doing that with this okay
[Laughter]
what is it and she was like
you just you know you don't want ice
with milk and i was like have you ever
drank ice with milk and she was like no
and i said well then what's the problem
and she was like well it's just you know
you just you just you have your rules
and i was like that's not my rule that's
like putting icing peanut butter
so i [ __ ] uh
i don't know man
one time i was eating cereal with my
friend mitch
and he was and i was like and he had
cereal too and we were both eating
cereals late at night and i was like you
want something to drink and he was like
what
i was like do you want something to
drink i'm going to the fridge and he was
like i'm eating cereal and i was like
what are you talking about and he was
like why would i want something to drink
while i'm eating cereal and i was like
am i what's happening and he was like
that's like asking do you want water
when you're drinking water and i don't
agree with them but i think i think
about it all the time dude
cause he thinks milk is in it dude and
you're just drinking and eating at the
same time
[ __ ] man
i don't know man i i drink [ __ ] spicy
water with with when i when i meet when
i'm eating when i'm eating cereal
i don't know
football's back do we give a [ __ ] about
that i think that's that's cool right
i'm gonna watch monday night football
with my friend david sullivan because he
really wants to and the guy [ __ ]
keeps trying to cancel on me man he's
like nah i'm not coming over and i'm
like we gotta watch some bad movies dude
i don't like good movies man
somebody sent me the in the indiana
jones trailer that's gonna come out now
i'm like [ __ ] what is it indiana
jones six five it's like i don't
okay
harrison sports 80.
like you know
he's what is he eight he's 80 what is he
he's like 85
it's like
and get a new indie didn't they try to
make shiloh buff indiana jones like his
son or some [ __ ]
wasn't there aliens in that one
what's up with indiana jones they just
don't really know what the [ __ ] to do
anymore there was aliens in the last one
and now they're gonna have them be 85
swinging a rope looking for the holy
grail
i was never in the jones fan too much
brown in the movie
um
obama watched that trailer uh my buddy
sent it to me and he was like you should
watch i can't wait for it i'm like nah
dude
um
this is great though
right here
twist is a ventriloquist now
the rapper
what up y'all it's your boy twister and
this is the most
thing i've ever seen in my [ __ ] life
dude you know how fast he wrapped he was
just like
but sentences dude
chris would just be like
but saying sentences that fast and now
dude first of all he's got a [ __ ]
ventriloquist with a backwards hat on
and a shirt that i would wear from
american apparel in [ __ ] 2006.
and twista is sitting there dude
and this is
hey hey hey
dude
dude
ventriloquism
sucks
hey
it's
2022. we're done with that like we're
done with mimes
you know why
there are video games that you can just
literally insert yourself in
we're hey
ventriloquism we're past that
hey twista weird hobby
hey hey what's up i can do it dude you
know
i feel like honestly if i tried hard for
a day i could be one of the best
ventriloquists
in the world
hey hey what's up hey i'm little chris
dude i'm good
hey what's up
i'm little chris what's going on what
what the [ __ ]
hey what the [ __ ] somebody left the door
open
[Laughter]
hey chris hey hey dick chris get your
hand out of my anus
that that's where it is you know
yeah i i know little i know little chris
hey hey little chris
just [ __ ] drinking with it
god how stupid
it's 2022 twister
that was a live introduction
and you know it
do it yourself you don't need the
[ __ ] that's impressive on its own
dude
he's making all those noises with his
[ __ ] mouth and then all he's doing is
this
i don't even know what this puppet is
[ __ ] saying you know
oh really
yeah
dude i gotta have a [ __ ]
ventriloquist act for real like i i'm
talking about go in do two nights
do one is my comedy [ __ ] and the next
one is crystalia and lil chris
ventriloquism at its finest
and then the next night i sell tickets
for my ventriloquist act and i don't
even practice
[Laughter]
hey guys welcome to the show thanks so
much before i bring little chris out i
hey what do you mean what oh [ __ ] i
guess he came prematurely
you got the same problem don't you
ah [ __ ]
stop roasting me
oh god damn man just not practicing
i'm little chris
buddy don't say shorty
dude my dad saw this a little twisted
doing ventriloquism he wouldn't
understand what was happening and he's
pretty with it you know for a 74 year
old
my dad would just be like who's that and
what is that saying and also the guy
what is he saying
and i'd say he'd say twister and i'd be
like no like yeah but it's twista oh
okay and he's a singer that's what he
would that's what the whole conversation
would be i'd be like he's a rapper oh
okay
who does he rap with he did a big song
with jamie foxx
the actor
yeah it's
never mind
twister and then he'd walk away
often tall
so loud dude wow that's
i mean what the [ __ ] dude
what up y'all it's your boy twister and
uh hey hey hey it's not trusting you
dude
dude
you know
just
a little twister you dig he's trying so
hard not to move like
trying so not to move that it's making
it like it's weirdly still like you
nobody
when the dude it's so funny
ventriloquist when the puppet's talking
they're like this
[Laughter]
dude
hey what's going on little twister is
everything good yes we're fine
we're all good you know
yeah so anyway hey how cool are you
catatonic right
now wow dude
and i make you a celebrity overnight
and i make you a little bit overnight
and i make you a celebrity overnight
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
so uh yeah so football's back and i'm
i'm gonna watch monday night football
dude and i want to watch and i don't
give a [ __ ] who's on but my friend david
sullivan is coming over and he was in a
docking dude david sullivan told me
about a [ __ ] documentary we had to
watch that his friend was in he was like
my friend just happens to be a [ __ ]
in a documentary and i was like oh
really it was like yeah his parents are
all over it and i was like really what's
it about he's like january 6 the
insurrection i was like really and he
was like yeah it's all about the storm
of the capitol building it's [ __ ]
crazy we gotta watch it it's like really
i was like what what streaming platform
is it on and he was like i don't know
let me look oh and the pictures of the
phone look to the network he's like oh
it's on a website and i was like well
here we go dude
what the how bad could this be if it's
not even on a roku
it's not even a [ __ ]
cartoon on crunchyroll like this [ __ ]
isn't even [ __ ] there's not a sneak
peek of it on shutter
it's on a web
i guess i could just screen share it i
was like okay okay bro you know just put
it on and he puts it on dude and the
documentary is about january 6 and we at
least think we're going to get both
sides of the story if you're making a
documentary about january 6 it's
probably going to be in the vein of what
these people did to storm the capital
are wrong it's at least going to be that
it may be
what these people did are wrong but
let's also talk to these people and see
where their heads at but it wasn't any
of that it was
this is why the insurrection or whatever
at capital the capitol building was the
right thing to do
and here i'm sitting watching it and i'm
realizing this and i'm like
when's your friend come in and what's he
gonna be saying
and we watch it and the dude is his
friend and he's [ __ ] like yeah well
we had to do this because it's a nat and
i look over at david and david's like oh
and i'm like
dude
were you part of january 6 and he was
like wow dude there's one guy talking to
the [ __ ] uh camera and he was just
like i was standing there in the crowd i
don't know what the [ __ ] documentary
was called i got to remember what i got
to figure out he was like i was standing
there in the crowd and i just knew the
right thing to do was to break into the
capitol building when i saw scriptures
physical scriptures come down from the
heavens
like a big billboard and i read them and
it told me to storm the capital and the
documentarian was filming it with music
that made you know that the
documentarian was on the guy's side
and i'm just sitting there like what the
[ __ ] and little chris is like hey what's
going on in there
who's your friend and how come you're
friends with the [ __ ] black jobs
so now i'm gonna watch monday night
football with this [ __ ] and i'm
like
you know
i don't give a [ __ ] who's the president
man we're [ __ ] no matter what that's
the whole thing about this but he's a
nihilist you know
but it's all good but he's a nihilist
because i don't give a [ __ ] who the as
long as the president isn't woke as [ __ ]
we're all good like biden is just a
[ __ ] puppet with all the
[ __ ] behind him
i don't know i don't like any president
i i have not liked any president since
nixon my favorite kidding i have no idea
i'm political you know what i mean
but football's back so we're gonna be
that and i like how um
i guess what's his name the [ __ ] tom
the most famous one
tom brady
is uh
doing um
he's gonna play another he keeps coming
out of retirement like he's [ __ ]
jay-z
like he's and he's doing uh
another season and now giselle bunchen
or whatever the [ __ ] her last name is is
is she's like well [ __ ] she moved out
she moved out because she was like you
gotta you
i want you to spend time with the kids
and it's like it's crazy to think of tom
brady because i you know i understand
that kind of mentality because you know
like when i do stand up
i don't know i guess for a while i
didn't want to really do it anymore two
years ago but
now i i i fell in love with it again and
i love being on stage and then i'm
thinking about like
if i were never able to to able to do it
ever again would i would like what is
there to prove but it's different though
because he's already won so much and is
obviously the best
to keep wanting to play to me i don't
know maybe that's why i don't have that
mindset you know maybe i've never been
i've never been competitive but like
i i can't believe he wants to play again
and i get what gisele is saying
because it's like at some point
you made a billion dollars
you're chilling and you can continue to
make a billion dollars it's not like
the well of money that you [ __ ] dip
from is going away because of
investments and
and endorsements and deals and [ __ ] like
that and restaurants you're probably
gonna make you know and a [ __ ] you
probably
uh you know have
stock and whatever company is making a a
you know in some ayahuasca company
that's going to be huge in [ __ ] nine
years you know
and uh or or robotics or whatever the
[ __ ] those those dog robots they have he
probably invested in that he's going to
be a trillionaire but whatever it is
it's like he just wants to play dude
and at some point i kind of understand
what gisele's saying because it's like
dude i take my son on the road with me
and when he doesn't come with me which
is yet
which hasn't happened yet
i don't think
um
and if i don't get to take my family
with me i'm gonna be like really upset
and lonely and what i told you in the
beginning of the podcast is i hate being
lonely because that's when you got to
sit and actually think about what the
[ __ ] is going on especially when you're
open doors
especially when the [ __ ] doors be
really open and the windows be really
open too
and your chimney really be unclogged
and so
it's like
how many years does he need to throw a
ball
because that's the thing
if i'm tom brady
which i am
and if my wife is giselle bundchen which
she is
and my kid are all of tom brady's kids
which he is
and my
wife is like i don't want you to do
another tour i want you to be with my i
want you to be with the kid i would have
some sort of resentment about it but
ultimately i want to be with the kid but
i don't know what the [ __ ] their day to
day is i mean they probably they
probably follow him she probably wants
them to be stable well i'm supposing a
lot of [ __ ] i don't see what i'm doing
this is what bloggers do and then they
write a [ __ ] piece and then it's like
[ __ ] tom brady for doing this [ __ ] but i
don't know the answer so i guess i'm
just talking it out thanks for the
therapy session my babies
um
i don't know
let's see what's up go get ticket to
crystalia.com i'll be in stockton and
oakland and [ __ ] raleigh and savannah
georgia
um
denver boston we added a second show
the [ __ ] wang filled up
3 500 seats we added another one dude
uh let's sell that one out too my babies
and uh i'm starting to tease you a
little bit with these [ __ ] chicago
you know i am playing peoria and
rockford but i'm teasing you with
chicago and i'm teasing you with new
york your boy might be there in the next
beginning of the next year he just might
he just might be there in san diego i'm
also going to be oh in phoenix i added a
date or sorry tempe and then oxnard i
just added a date oxnard california but
whatever dude let's look at some of
these [ __ ]
let's look at the tinder first we always
do that
oh yeah i know i know i know seinfeld
did the kid thing and i did kind of want
to talk about that because you know i
like kith i always rep keith and then
seinfeld's just like 60 wearing kith and
stuff but they didn't they do it with um
god i always forget his name
who
buscemi and then they also did it with
uh
didn't they do it with the [ __ ] uh
jeff goldblum or no
did there was a gucci or something
whatever but anyway i like when they do
with the old guys man but now it's like
what am i gonna wear [ __ ] exactly the
same thing that seinfeld has wearing
like [ __ ] i mean so new york you know
the way he's posing and [ __ ] with his
hat
so i felt just like this
i saw a clip where [ __ ] seinfeld was
like but that's why a joke is matt would
you say that's why a joke is magic i
think a joke is magic
a miracle even worse i think a joke is a
miracle and it's like
oh yeah
a miracle is a miracle
a joke's a miracle a joke's a miracle
one time i was watching an interview
with [ __ ] um jerry lewis and he was
just like and they were they were asking
him about his comedy about how something
was like i don't know if it was like
something that was like
uh either
the way either like sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't you know talking
about the hardships of it and he just
goes like this
that's comedy babe
uh
uh
ah
that's comedy babe dude imagine you
seriously said to somebody that's comedy
babe hey and no matter what you work at
you can work at a [ __ ] coffee shop
that's that's you know what that's
machado babe
that's the way [ __ ] that's like
saying the cookie that's where the
cookie crumbles it's like you're
seriously gonna be one of those guys
that's some old school [ __ ] that's
comedy babe dude i gotta start saying
that that's comedy babe
um
yeah
dude i saw a truck in atlanta that was
so [ __ ] big
it was so big
you can't get in it
it was it had it was so big
it needed it needed a fire escape
it was
so big
it was a plane i mean it was so big dude
and it must have been
a
million five hundred thousand dollars
and then some really short dude got in
it was [ __ ] amazing man
it was amazing he hopped up
he hopped up into the thing like he did
a chin up to get into it
he did a muscle up he just went
and got in dude
it was unbelievable and he started this
the car and went
dang think tank
[Music]
come on everybody now
wait not yet everybody know what this is
this part this part's me uh i got you
guys
tonight
[Laughter]
hey
[ __ ] yeah dude
this is the podcast
okay that was a great episode we had a
good fun time thank you very much for
listening and having a you know dude you
can go to uh get your pure spectrum
gummies going over get your 10 off uh
they got all things uh
cbd and uh use the code congrats it's in
the show notes below the video
and uh and all that i got uh on coming
up here stockton california on tour
oakland california i'll be there
hollywood california oxnard california
peoria illinois rockford illinois
raleigh north carolina and savannah
can't wait to do raleigh in savannah
tempe arizona denver colorado bellco
theater cheyenne wyoming boston
massachusetts albany new york lakeland
florida and jacksonville florida and i
will be adding more next year
come on out and see me that's it for the
episode on youtube if you want to catch
the rest of the episode the uncut
unedited
raw
episode
sign up on our patreon
patreon.com and for only six bucks a
month you can get
every episode we do an extra episode a
month that is not available for the
public only for the patreon members and
you can get those and as soon as you
sign up you get access to all of the
ones that we've done so far i think
we've done like 17 so far so you can go
watch them now you can also watch our
our thing that we do review mode and
then i do sometimes i do a podcast thing
with kristin um you get a content all
that content so go on over to crystallia
uh sorry patreon.com and uh go check it
out thanks a lot guys
[Music]